>>> IN OUR WORLD LEAD TODAY,
U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THAT RUSSIA
IS BUYING MILLIONS OF ARTILLERY
SHELLS AND ROCKETS FROM NORTH
KOREA.
IT'S A SIGN THAT SANCTIONS AND
EXPORT CONTROLS ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO RUSSIA'S DEPLETING WEAPONS
SUPPLY.
THIS AS NUCLEAR INSPECTORS ARE
CALLING FOR A SAFETY ZONE AROUND
THE ZAPORIZHZHIA POWER PLANT IN
UKRAINE WHICH RUSSIA CONTROLS.
THEIR REPORT WARNS THAT THE
PLANT IS UNDER CONSTANT THREAT
FROM A POTENTIAL NUCLEAR
DISASTER AMID ONGOING SHELLING
BOTH ON SITE AND AROUND THE
AREA.
MEANWHILE, UKRAINE'S
COUNTEROFFENSIVE AGAINST RUSSIAN
FORCES CONTINUES IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THAT COUNTRY.
CNN'S SAM RILEY REPORTS NOW ON
THE FOREIGN FIGHTERS JOINING
UKRAINIANS ON THE FRONT LINES
AND A WARNING, SOME VIEWERS MAY
FIND PARTS OF THIS REPORT
DISTURBING.
>> GO, GO, GO.
NO PANIC.
THIS NORMAL.
>> AMONG THE MOST FORWARD TROOPS
IN UKRAINE'S LATEST
COUNTEROFFENSIVE, THIS REALLY IS
NORMAL.
WHEN THE CRUNCH OF INCOMING
ARTILLERY IS THIS INTENSE,
CASUALTIES IN THIS
RECONNAISSANCE UNIT WHICH
INCLUDES THREE FOREIGNERS, ARE
INEVITABLE.
A BRITON WAS LIGHTLY WOUNDED, ON
DAY TWO, HE WAS MORE SERIOUSLY
INJURED IN THE LEG BY ARTILLERY
ALONG WITH A FORMER U.S. MARINE
FROM KANSAS.
HE WAS HIT IN THE HAND, STOMACH,
AND HEAD.
THEY JOINED UKRAINE'S ARMY
TOGETHER.
BUT MET FIGHTING ISIS IN SYRIA.
HE'S THE FORMER U.S. MARINE'S
KURDISH CODE NAME.
THEY HAVE BEEN THE TIP OF
UKRAINE'S ATTACKS ON ITS
SOUTHERN FRONT IN THE FOIG TO
RECAPTURE KHERSON.
>> I REMEMBER LOOKING TO MY LEFT
AND POP, I COULDN'T SEE ANYTHING
FOR A BIT.
EVERYTHING LOOKED THE SAME.
EVERYTHING CAME TO.
LOOKED AT MY LEFT, LOOKED LIKE.
LOOKED AT MY RIGHT, [ BLEEP ]ED
THERE, TO THE HOLE.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A SLOW
GRINDING FIGHT, THEY SAY.
WHATEVER THE CLAIMS OF UKRAINE'S
GOVERNMENT.
THIS COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS BEING
BILLED AS KIND OF A QUICK
PROCESS.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S --
>> NO, DEFINITELY NOT.
IT WON'T BE QUICK.
IT'S HARD, SLOW FOUGHT, BY ME,
POSITION BY POSITION.
WE HAVEN'T GOT RESOURCES TO DO A
MASSIVE BLITZKRIEG.
>> U.S. WEAPONS AND OTHER NATO
EQUIPMENT HAVE PROVED USEFUL.
BUT NOT DECISIVE AS UKRAINE HAS
CAPTURED A HANDFUL OF VILLAGES
SINCE THE COUNTEROFFENSIVE
BEGAN.
HERE, RUSSIAN TROOPS WAVE A
WHITE FLAG OF SURRENDER.
PRECISION ARTILLERY STRIKES BY
U.S. SUPPLIES HOWITZERS ARE
MONITORED BY THE UNIT WITH A
DRONE.
RUSSIA'S MOTIVATED ITS TROOPS
WITH FALSE CLAIMS THAT THEY'RE
LIBERATING UKRAINE FROM NAZIS.
FOR UKRAINE, IT'S A BATTLE OF
NATIONAL SURVIVAL.
ATTRACTING HELP FROM AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> DO YOU FEEL SORRY FOR THE
RUSSIANS?
>> NO.
NOT AT ALL.
IT'S NOT LIKE UKRAINE HAS
INVADED RUSSIA.
THEY HAVE INVADED UKRAINE.
THEY'RE HERE KILLING CIVILIANS,
KILLING OUR SOLDIERS.
I HAVE NO SYMPATHY FOR THEM
WHATSOEVER.
>> UKRAINE'S IMPOSED A NEWS
BLACKOUT ON THE SOUTHERN
OFFENSIVE AND KEEPS ITS CASUALTY
FIGURES SECRET, BUT FOR THESE
MEN BEING WOUNDED ISN'T THE END
OF COMBAT.
IT'S AN INTERRUPG.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO GO BACK?
>> YEAH, ONCE EVERYTHING HEALS
ON MY BODY, PROBABLY WITHIN
THREE TO FOUR WEEKS, I SHOULD BE
BACK OUT THERE.
>> NOW, JAKE, ONE OF THE
IMMEDIATE RESULTS OF THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS THAT THE
RUSSIAN APPOINTED AUTHORITIES IN
KHERSON, WHICH IS THE ONLY
REGIONAL CAPITAL THE RUSSIANS
HAVE CAPTURED IN MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS OF FIGHTING HAVE AT LEAST
SHELVES OR TEMPORARILY ABANDONED
PLANS TO CARRY OUT AN ILLEGAL
REFERENDUM, PART OF THEIR
EFFORTS THEY HAVE ALSO BEEN
TRYING TO GET OFF THE GROUND
ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTRY IN
AREAS THEY HAVE SEIZED TO
SUGGEST THE LOCAL POPULATION IS
IN FAVOR OF BEING INVADED AND
MIGHT EVEN WANT TO JOIN THE
WIDER RUSSIAN BODY POLITIC.
THAT HAS B